avec nous Mario Léonet professeur
faculté de médecine et de sciences de
Sherbrooke c'est Léonie bonsoir
bonsoir donc revenez sur le consulat
vous avez vu les chiffres vous les avez
comparé le recul est quand même vraiment
impressionnant par rapport à il y a 35
ans
absolument bon nous ce qu'on a constaté
c'est bon les chiffres ont été
mentionnés tantôt dans le mini reportage
que vous avez présenté bon au niveau de
la capacité cardiovasculaire elle-même
là c'est à dire l'unité métabolique qui
est interprétée par le VO2max une chute
de 18% 12% pour les filles c'est quand
même un phénomène qui est significatif
mais ce qui est encore peut-être un peu
plus dérangeant c'est la chute de 30% de
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de la
capacité fonctionnelle des jeunes c'est
à dire la capacité de fournir un effort
puis de la soutenir
tel qu'indiquer par le nombre de paliers
complétés par exemple dans le test de
course navette quand vous avez commencé
à jouer là dedans les chiffres de 35 ans
les chiffres de 2017 est-ce que vous
vous attendiez est-ce qu'il y a une
dégradation aussi grande de la santé
cardiovasculaire des jeunes
de façon anecdotique en parlant avec des
gens qui sont prêts des jeunes qui
pensent entre autres éducateurs
physiques bon ceux qui ont le minimum
d'expérience ceux qui sont là depuis je
peux disons 20 ans rapportait souvent
que eux constataient des différences
importantes entre les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui et bon ceux qui avaient au
début de leur carrière donc on
s'attendait à ça puis on le voyait aussi
on voit qu'il y a plus d'obésités il y a
plus d'un bon point non c'est toutes des
facteurs qui favorisent pas une bonne
performance au niveau cardiovasculaire
ce qui nous a plus surpris c'est
l'ampleur que ça là et il y a une donnée
en particulier qui est particulièrement
frappante c'est quand qu'on regarde au
niveau du seuil qui est un peu un
indicateur de protection contre
d'éventuels problèmes cardiométabolique
alors chez les garçons on parle de 42 ml
aux alentours pour les filles autour de
37 et on constate que en 82 peu importe
le groupe d'âge de 6 à 17 ans tout le
monde était largement au-dessus de cette
valeur seuil qui protège éventuellement
contre les troubles que je viens de
mentionner en 2017 ce qu'on constate
c'est qu'à l'âge de 17 ans 58% des
garçons et 70% des filles de 17 ans et
bon de 17 ans et plus on atteint un
seuil en deux sorts de cette valeur
critique là ce qui veut dire que ça les
expose éventuellement à des problèmes de
santé à plus ou moins long terme bon et
ça on a montré on montre les chiffres ça
c'est important vous dites à l'époque
oui il y en a qui était un peu moins en
forme des des jeunes mais personne ou à
peu près personne était sous le seuil
dangereux là qui peut avoir des
conséquences plus tard sur des
cardiovasculaires etc et aujourd'hui
c'est énorme 58% sous le seuil critique
70% des filles c'est ça la lumière rouge
de vos études
le principal élément qui est inquiétant
c'est ça parce que ce que ça veut dire
c'est que dès l'âge de 17 ans puis même
souvent chez les filles par exemple on
est en bas du 50% là c'est à dire on
atteint la le seuil de 50 % et plus plus
élevé de
signe inquiétant dès l'âge de 16 ans ce
qui veut dire que dès l'âge de 17 ans là
tu as plus que la moitié des jeunes qui
actuellement sont dans une situation où
il s'expose à un risque qui va aller en
grandissant de développer des problèmes
comme le diabète l'obésité bon puis même
éventuellement chez les adolescents on
commence même à avoir des codes
d'hypertension artérielle
Mario Léonet je demandais à la ministre
à mon émission assure RDI plutôt
qu'est-ce qu'on fait a dit on encourage
les jeunes à bouger dans les écoles on
essaie de trouver une heure quand on
accumule les récréations et tout ça fait
une heure de bouger mais ce que les
experts disent puis corrigez-moi si je
me trompe c'est que ça prend une heure
mais devrait éducation physique par jour
le pas juste il faut qu'il bouge il faut
qu'ils augmentent leur capacité
justement pulmonaire puis cardiaque
il y a beaucoup d'études qui démontent
que quand les périodes d'activité
d'éducation physique sont plus
nombreuses et aussi en termes de temps
plus longues c'est pas des périodes de
15 minutes on parle de une heure bon au
moins trois à quatre fois par semaine
sinon même 5 fois certaines écoles
préconiser même 5 fois semaine on
constate que ça le des effets et
excessivement bénéfiques sur sur leur
état de santé général mais aussi sur
évidemment sur leur condition physique
d'abord mais aussi c'est ça ça écarte
les possibilités de développer les
problèmes métaboliques dont on parlait
tantôt parce que leur niveau de forme
est plus élevé donc plus résistant aux
maladies évidemment moins de fatigue
parce que tu es plus en forme bon et
tout ce que tout ce qui décolle de ça
donc
c'est ça donc on a intérêt à mettre en
place des mesures qui vont permettre de
corriger ça
vous avez comparé les données du Québec
puis ces 3500 je pense qui était dans le
questionnaire dans l'examen est-ce que
soit intuitivement ou est-ce que vous
avez vu des données pour d'autres
endroits sur la planète est-ce que des
endroits où on fait mieux ce que des
endroits où les résultats sont plus
positifs est-ce qu'on a ces comparatifs
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ces
réversible tout ça mais il faut mettre
des mesures en place on peut s'inspirer
de ce que faisait les jeunes dans les
années 80 il faisait bah si on réussit à
reproduire ça avec les évidemment les
contraintes des années 2020 là mais
d'acier de se rapprocher de ça on
améliorerait probablement sensiblement
le les résultats qu'on voit actuellement
très claire merci beaucoup Mario Leone
professeur Faculté de Médecine sciences
la santé Université de Sherbrooke merci
de nous avoir parlé
ça me fait plaisir merci au